ich möchte euch erstmal in ruhe lassen
ich bin pazifist ich möchte frieden
ich kämpfe für die gerechtigkeit und oh
mein gott aus leuten sind wir gespannt
übrigens er wollte eine troll riot games
und herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen
folge hunger games auf dem halm pixel
server ich kann mal ganz kurz die kluft
bestätigen damit ihr seht was hier so
abgeht
es ist gerade noch halb drei ich aus der
schule übels heiß ist und 36 grad man
hält es draußen nicht aus ist einfach
übel schwül-warm ich jetzt draußen legen
dazu ja heute kommt ja schon mega
projekt aber dann habe ich mir gedacht
wo er das recht zu stickig dann nehme
ich lieber hier drinnen schönen kühlen
runde hunger games verkauft mal kurz
wieder die uhr damit dass hier ein
bisschen erträglicher erscheint ihr
wolltet ihr alle viel mehr hunger games
haben die eine folge verdacht mehr gebe
ich dem dänen da ein bisschen mehr von
bvb kann man jetzt nicht nur hunger
games sieht sie auch noch nicht nur zwei
games dann noch feldbauer oder ventures
oder split oder world of warcraft das
werdet ihr alles noch bei mir sehen
könnte man die kommentare schreiben
als nächstes haben wollte und jetzt noch
ganz weit organisatorische sachen
erstmal das erste und zwar youtubes next
minecraft ist das turnier das ich mit
mojang minecraft gemacht habe
findet ihr in der beschreibung und y tn
m.de da sind nun die finalteilnehmer und
ihr könnt ihr dann oder kennt mich
konkreter da könnt ihr jetzt abstimmen
wer von denen den gewinnen soll ab der
zwei wochen zeit und allgemeiner noch
der kanal youtube snacks minecraft ist
in der beschreibung also da könnt ihr
abstimmen wer dieses turnier für euch
gewinnen sollte wer mit mir ein projekt
gewinnen soll wie eine paysafecard
gewinn soll et cetera zweite sache
freunde von mir machen auch jetzt
youtube-videos und zwar heißen die lost
als die machen so call of duty die
wollten eventuell bald auch microsoft
machen habe ich von ihm gehört von
patrick und die machen auch happy meals
und was alles und ich finde für den
anfang eigentlich mit einer relativ
guten qualität die haben jetzt noch
nicht mehr ärgert oder so vielleicht ein
bisschen weiter helfen allerdings ist
auch ein link in der beschreibung die
wollte jetzt einfach mal
support weil den freunde blablabla also
da könnte er verbaut vorbeigucken
abonnieren wenn ihr wollt doch da
versuchen leute blöcke abzubauen gut und
jetzt geht es auch eigentlich los und
zwar joint einfach mal hier und da
spielen wir wie heißen die map ich weiß
ja wie die heißt es war eine komische
übrigens mache ich in zweifel games
immer das ganze auf normal 64 warum ich
finde es besser wenn man ganz weit
hinten nicht diese ganzen sachen sieht
und dann ist das auf einmal vorbei
sondern das soll ruhig so ein bisschen
nebel sein sage ich mal
nein ich mache kein team mit euch in
lucia sicherer ohne team im nacken alter
okay 7
noch gar nicht oder hatten wir die schon
wenn da oben im vergleich zum drache ist
dann hab ich schon mal gespielt übrigens
meinen noch einige dass ich fit
aussuchen soll mit dem bogen
naja ok und zwar kann nicht mehr dann so
sachen halt aussuchen travel one small
step for man übrigens er wollte eine
treue reihe troll hunger games troll
games dann irgendwie weil ich bin mal
kurz diese troll klasse dann könnte ich
aber für
oder ich weiß nicht ich ich wird ein
paar und mit dem trading spielen
schreibt einfach mal wenn ihr troll
folgen haben wollt und dann mache ich
das man aber jetzt nicht mal was anderes
und weil
das ich werde vielleicht auch bald wie
bekomme ich hab da häufig sind schon
angeschrieben hat möglich macht aber
ganz kurze besuche halte das möglich sei
der meinte daniel schreibt er bald
zurück in zehn sekunden zeit wegläuft
und eine mitte ich glaube ich suche die
kiste da weil da steht keiner jaja die
nehme ich zwei
oh jetzt aber noch ein bogen drin aber
ich laufe jetzt lieber mal schnell weg
anstatt hier weitere sachen zu riskieren
der versucht schon bäume abzubauen sind
das survival games in hunger games von
daher kann er nicht abbauen also hatten
als essayist in survival games aber ich
nenne es hunger games so ich sags mal so
warum da sind schon leute die sind
wahrscheinlich im team hätten bessere
ausrüstung als ich glaube ich wir sind
euch wieso geht jetzt auf mich der soll
auf seinen komischen kumpanen da drauf
gehen und schon auf mich ich möchte euch
erstmal in ruhe lasse ich bin pazifist
ich möchte frieden
ich kämpfe für die gerechtigkeit und oh
mein gott außerdem sind wir gespannt
das hat mir sehr viel gebracht
übrigens tipper games nimmt immer ach so
lag ich auf meine alten übrigens dann
auch wenn ich dieses komischen
allerdings binnen 60 sekunden glaube ich
und da kriegt man immer geschwindigkeit
wenn das stimmt das haben wir ganz viele
leute die kommentare geschrieben eine
weitere tricks wissen können wir das
auch mal ein kommentar schreiben
beziehungsweise die beste kit vorschlag
oder so was ihr mann könnte mir auch in
die kommentare schreiben
halt so ein paar normale sachen die
alten normaler club in minecraft halt
braucht dementsprechend ich aber ich
liebe diesen server deswegen ihr könnt
mir einfach schreiben was er als
nächstes haben wollt also craig kraft
oder halt irgendwie retro games also
hunger treue oder ich will mein kräfte
games nennen oder irgend sowas hätte ich
auch mal lust daran nehme ich dann
einfach immer das troll kit ob sonne
geträumt wird oder nicht am schnellsten
throl games also immer wenn ihr seht
dann throl games in titel dann ist es
mit geil
ja dann bin ich gerne dann ist es mit
dingsbums künftig weg hier
nee dann ist es mit dem treue kit ich
habe angst dass einer hinter mir ist ich
glaube hier fliegt doch irgendein neuer
befinden schwimmend gesehen also nochmal
aufs auch um auf den anfang
zurückzukommen youtube sex minecraft
geht in die finale runde in der
beschreibung sind die links
und eben noch zehn spieler und freunde
von mir die auch youtube videos machen
findet ihr auch in der beschreibung
könntet ihr einfach mal vorbeischauen
ihr müsst ja nichtmal abonnieren aber
auf jeden fall mal vorbei standort für
euch ist vielleicht bald auch was mit
dem machen ich weiß er nicht bald wie
kann ich das eigentlich nur verbinden
das geht doch irgendwie den optikern
euro gehen dagegen das nicht in wenigen
ob die feineinstellungen so viele
verdammte schwertern es ist unnormal
ich schaue mal ganz kurz die tales
schnecke textes fancy klappt läuft super
ich weiß ich weiß einige meint ich soll
man texte wegnehmen ich hab ja text
rapax aber ich finde irgendwie weil ich
dachte der macht kein frieden deswegen
sorry sorry sorry aber ich dachte der
macht kein frieden weil die ganze zeit
vorher irgendwie so auf mich zugelaufen
ist deswegen nicht auf dich hab' das zu
spät gesehen leute tut mir leid
ja geil
sorry leute falls jetzt einige meine ich
sei total der verräter aber ich wusste
nicht dass der uli das hätte jetzt aber
schon sehen können
na komm komm ich
soll der kommen soll der kommen bis
dahin ist mein leben hoffentlich wieder
voll bis der bei mir ist was heißt das
eigentlich blitzt da was was soll das
heißen freunde schreibt wenn meine
kommentare was mit blitz da gemeint ist
der svs ranzig ich hatte ja solche leute
die einfache entfernung spielen
das regt mich übelst 11 und es dann
nicht mehr können ojo geschwindigkeit ja
so irgendwann gleich kommt der
überraschungsmoment um wo ich mich dann
einfach umdrehen
wo bisher
das akku
das weg komisch also noch drei spieler
puh da bin ich froh dass ich ihn kommen
bin neu
ich warte jetzt einfach mal ab
also ich meine da steht ja gar sechs
sekunden da passiert dann in brasilia
deathmatch dann stelle ich jetzt erstmal
runde so die beiden
wie soll sich da ist man bekämpfen diese
kann ich jetzt nicht schlagen you cannot
damage anyone also ok nummer eins
leider gewinnt erhält viel bessere
sachen ja ja okay das war klar
na gut ich wurde zweiter haben also ich
hab es insgesamt nur drei kills obmann
na gut oder war das jetzt nur für die
runde ich weiß es nicht also ist man so
eine kleine kleine hunger games runde wo
am rande schreibt mir wie schon gesagt
in die kommentare ob ihr traum games
wollte richter disco-hit nehmen oder was
ihr von diesen sachen als nächstes
wollte pvp mäßig ob ihr paintball wohl
bloß the walls oder quake kräftig
twittern the walls ausgang mich dann
einfach mit leuten zusammen finden hier
the world ist es aber da spielt man das
alleine werde ich mich noch darüber
informieren werde ich alles testen was
ist das hier für transport ist es bonn
wer sich also dieser komplettes wasser
e-mails geil aufgebaut altern das ist
schöner bereiche so viel screenshot bald
werde ich mich auch wieder die shader
reinpacken mich am set up mich damit zu
befassen erstmals er wieder klausuren
und ja freunde dann würde ich erst mal
sagen wenn es euch gefallen hat daumen
hoch geben schreibt mir die sachen die
kommentare was ich halt gesagt habe
und dann
das ist auch schön so mit dem schwert
haben da so gut
wir sehen uns beim nächsten mal wieder
deuce